[Music]
in the verdict is in new Oh
submitted by for the culture ASAP Rocky
was found guilty of assault in Sweden oh
really really went there devil from that
video it seemed like he was trying to
de-escalate the whole thing I heard that
we didn't have all the video because
afterwards he got like a bottle and
smashed it over the bad drunk guys I
think that's okay I think if you try to
de-escalate and people still step to you
then you can do whatever the [ __ ] you
want after that's like when you go hey
step back I know karate
and then you [ __ ] use karate that's
you warned them if the [ __ ] know
step back hey all the karate use all
that well what are you gonna do go to
jail for using kicks like don't like war
dumb I know karate man hmm
I told my dad back yeah did he use
karate karate you sure you should have
been like slappers only let's go slap
I'll have to warn you I'm a black belt
in Taekwondo yeah ain't that what he
looks like
yo girls really fine ASAP Rocky
attractive yeah yeah good-looking dude
yeah well not aware of how attractive
women found his his eyes hmm I thought
it was his ravers haircut yeah he looks
like nice like he looks like honest I
drew mine did you - Plus jawline
handsome man - the proposed jawline
[ __ ] wife says he knows good nose [ __ ]
does it increase his beauty level the
fact that he is a musician and very
talented he's very fashionable yeah I
love that
what is that he's wearing a DMX chain
with a blazer there what a mix of
clothes there he's a fashion icon though
yeah yeah medium ki hai ki hai ki yeah
yeah
medium ki looks like what what Benj is
trying to do yeah
when he just loved my wedding he he went
to the girl that used to braid my hair
when my hair was long and asked her if
he could if she could do ASAP braids on
him yeah I know what I see so he's
inspired by a so inspired by ASAP Rocky
do we have more pictures of mr. handsome
ASAP guy so he posted on Instagram this
photo yeah he was a fashion icon he's
got some good in these rings oh I
thought that was a BMW look how clean
his cuticles are and moist Chinese I
heard that that was an attractive trait
that women enjoyed was nice nails on men
yeah they imagine the finger banging and
they say because you wouldn't want a guy
with like rusted dust beer nails all up
in your don't any nails no nails no no
torture no no they had no hands
oh that I'd be sick but no nail like B
nails no he's always talking about I
just want a difference I'm Laura Dunn a
dick or a tongue only how about if it
was like a pirate you take off his hook
and it's a nub
like that that could just for the story
okay because how often do you get that
offer that's true it might feel good you
know I know and then I couldn't say for
sure enough feels good there would know
at least okay so you captioned it with
this would you like to read sure I am of
course disappointed by today's verdict I
want to say thanks again to all of my
fans friends and everyone who showed me
love during this difficult time
i'ma keep moving forward thank you to my
team my management attorneys label and
everyone who advocated for justice
prayer hands down I need you guys so
they're saying that he was sentenced to
conditional sentences meaning he won't
have to serve any additional jail time
unless he commits another similar crime
in Sweden he was also ordered to pay a
fine of one thousand three hundred and
seventy that's fine
that's not like commit crimes there it's
so cheap and how long is the prison
sentence or the gym he has already
served nearly a month behind bars that's
a long time it's a long [ __ ] son
waiting for child so it was him and his
two bodyguards that had to serve time
and so they're saying like all right you
don't have to serve any more time just
don't move it again kind of like am on
vacation the fact that he um it's cuz he
pleaded self-defense during his trial
yeah saying that those two men were
harassing him in his entourage knew what
they were and but the courts determined
that they were not subject to a current
or imminent criminal attack and were not
in a situation where they were entitled
to self-defense hmm I beg to differ
no but he's like he's a he's a name he's
a you must never know what crazy
[ __ ] your face could do it was
a normal person fine I'll give that to
you yeah you don't have anything to gain
or they don't know they can gain values
yeah
this isn't Sweden or Sweden Swedish
never shopping in Ikea job guys violate
your personal space I think they could
get [ __ ] on yeah bro there's like uh
there's I think there's a range of when
you enter the fight zone you know what I
mean to me it's the arm's distance once
you pass the arms distance you're
entering the fight zone I'm curious do
you go like do you like measure like
you've been happening and you're like
okay he's so good so good don't don't
make me okay he's like well unless you
want all this karate bro yeah hug bag
this is the perimeter
I drew a [ __ ] circle if you entered
this [ __ ] perimeter you are dead this
is the [ __ ] kumite zone let's roll
down be careful I might wait working on
my black give you a couple years like
this don't make me do it and it's all in
court I could be like your honor I
warned him
I created a perimeter I said everyone
comes if you're entering the kumite
[Music]
showed up Mike weapons and he still did
not comply mm-hmm he entered the barrier
of the dangers yourself that's true who
knew Sweden was so strict with their
laws a lot of people are pretty much
like a lot of artists are saying like
we're not performing in Sweden anymore
oh oh wait I did hear some [ __ ] okay
hella and it gets into some dangerous
political zones because we don't know
yeah so so I don't know I don't know
I like politics like I like gossip all
right and I like to spread the news like
that way tell me okay so here's the
thing right so the migrant you know how
like recently a lot of the war refugees
in Syria know that they ran into Europe
right they're getting a bad rep because
some of the guys that's like coming from
these like refugee camps or whatever
they they kind of at night they would
rape the locals mmm and then so there's
two schools of thought one is um this is
like all right media in these countries
that are trying to make all Muslims look
like it's it's trying to like push Islam
Islamophobia or whatever you're right
but in I guess the the other camp is
like no we're under threat and we need
to do something because and they feel
like they're basically the media is
bearing or trying to hide a lot of this
or the government is trying to keep
people calm because they don't want
people to get scared so they're like you
need to let that people know that this
this dangerous [ __ ] is going on mm-hmm
but yeah it is just a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ] going on I don't really know
exactly because I don't live there but I
watched one like town hall meeting and
and they just did not want like a
refugee camp or a house that was full of
like migrants to to be in their area
because they were afraid of like the the
crime and the rape and all that stuff
and then people were like well you're
just getting fed that [ __ ] so you're a
zombie phobic but in other people were
like no this is really happening
ah it's just hard to tell what's going
on man you don't know believe yeah yeah
it's it's pretty crazy but I just got it
yeah yeah
no more IKEA man thank you but I've been
a Sweden and they're really nice people
you're gonna see yeah they're so [ __ ]
nice and yeah okay I can't good I can't
okay I went to this metal bar and
they're like you know like like crazy
screaming metal metal and sweet yeah
yeah
I'll head this we didn't but then you go
to the bar and the bartender he's got
like Mohawks and like piercings and he's
like hi how are you doing today we're
just where would you like to see life
amoeba yeah if I feel like it's such a
nice country with nice people right now
like what do they got to be like goth
about like goth is sad yeah you know I
mean like where's the style yeah Hot
Topic Sweden if you like wherever
there's white people you're gonna have
goth people yeah metal people
[Music]